[Musique]
il dit qu'il n'a pas de problème avec le
peuple turc
mais avec erdogan ça et moi monsieur
macron vous n'avez pas fini d'avoir des
ennuis avec moi 18 rafale français
acheté par la grèce la tension monte
encore d'un cran dans le duel en mer qui
dure depuis plusieurs semaines avec la
turquie
c'est l'ensemble des pays européens qui
devraient se mobiliser aujourd'hui pour
10 à la turquie et à la grèce ni l'un ni
l'autre vous exploiterez les
hydrocarbures en méditerranée notre
volonté c'est évidemment d'éviter
l'escaladé répond pas à la provocation
par la provocation sinon c'est justement
cette escalade qui arrive
face à ces menaces et pourtant vous le
savez nous avons des millions de
désaccord avec emmanuel macron je suis
résolument derrière emmanuel macron
président de la république française
très de deux ans après le tout début de
leur mobilisation les gilet jaune était
de retrait puis arrosé
c'est lui qui se voulait l'un des
leaders du peuple mécontent doit alors
battre en retraite dans un café jamais
c'est faire d une partie des gilet jaune
me reproche effectivement d'avoir
dénoncé les propos de jérôme rodriguez
qui a qualifié la police de nazis et
jérôme rodriguez j'ai vu qu'on lui
donnait beaucoup d' excuses pour avoir
tenu ces propos
j'aimerais savoir quelle excuse on lui
donne pour avoir été mis en cause pour
des violences conjugales dont il s'est
d'ailleurs vanté lors d'un débat public
avec la france 1 soumises aujourd'hui
c'est un appel à faire en sorte que
l'ensemble des gilet jaune se retrouvent
autour des revendications qui étaient
les nôtres au 17 novembre de faire
revenir les gilets jaunes dans la rue
d'attirer tous ceux qui sont en colère
aujourd'hui en france 10% désormais
seulement des français se sentent
proches du mouvement fait partie des 10
% c'est pas du tout son âge que j'ai dû
moi j'ai lu que 50% des français
comprenait encore les gilet jaune mais
je crois que les gilet jaune du début
sont plus légers les jeunes
d'aujourd'hui voilà les gilet jaune
d'aujourd'hui il ya sûrement encore des
gens qui sont sincères mais enfin ça
surtout été totalement noyautée par
l'extrême gauche et le problème de
l'extrême gauche c'est qu'elle pourrit
tout ce qu'elle touche pour eux il faut
se garder de toute récupération de tel
ou tel par mais en tout cas l'ordre
républicain a été globalement maintenue
il ya des gens qui ont été interpellés
le miso l'intérieur j'ai radar
maintenant on a dressé un bilan hier
soir aux côtés du préfet selon le
ministère de l'intérieur ils étaient
2500 cet après midi dans la capitale
275 personnes ont été interpellées 147
en garde à vue selon le parquet de paris
nous avons arrêté beaucoup de personnes
qui portaient les armes vous avez vu
d'ailleurs les photos ont été publiées
des armes extrêmement contente
extrêmement dangereuse d'où d'ailleurs
les très nombreuses gardes à vue qui ont
qui ont été mis en place
gérald darmanin qui ressemble comme deux
gouttes d'eau à emmanuel macron
aujourd'hui à nicolas sarkozy non à
emmanuel macron ce sont des matamores ce
personnage de la commedia dell'arte qui
revendiquent des grands des grands actes
de courage et qui au fond se dégonfle
comme des baudruches il n'y a plus
d'autorité dans ce pays quand le corps
social réagi il faut faire preuve
d'empathie de modestie de regarder ce
qui se passe et savoir rectifier très
probablement d'ailleurs c'est ce que
j'avais fait lorsque j'avais retiré la
taxe sa fameuse est classé l'écotaxe sûr
on me l'a reproché mais vous rendez
compte
j'ai évité au pays des mois et des mois
de manifestations et de blocage elle
existe et je parlais hier lors de nos
universités d'été à vendôme d'une haine
de classe qui s'est construite au cours
de ce quinquennat
je pense que cette haine de classe elle
demeure c'est pas parce quelques 6000
personnes qui a pas des millions de
français qui ont le sentiment finalement
que le pouvoir depuis trois ans les a
tout simplement ignoré la politique
c'est ma vie à jamais non je crois pas
ou alors peut-être on décroche des
responsabilités et des mandats mais on
ne décroche pas de la vie politique de
l'année il faut pas croire les
politiques qui disent on disparaît non
ils sont toujours là ils reviennent